oh gosh oh hello hello puppy I need help
I'm in pain
I mean horrible pain puppy help me open
hey guys how's it going no new reading
your comments today I'll probably push
that to a later date this week because
tomorrow I'm flying back to Cincinnati
to visit my friend and family for the
holiday hidden yeah right chica I just
wanted to do a vlog because I haven't
had a chance to do a vlog in a long time
it's mostly just been reading the
comments which is totally fine but there
are moments when I would like to just
speak from the heart with you guys and I
just want to comment that this past
month has been like really really
amazing for me and my friends creatively
because we did come back from a tragedy
you know we lost Daniel we lost a close
friend of ours and a lot of you guys out
there we're very worried about how we
would do and I just want to let you guys
know that with your support this month
has been like honestly amazing like so
many things have changed over this past
month so many things have been added so
many new things we've tried and we as a
group and I as an individual have been
able to push ourselves like farther than
we thought possible chica what's going
on what you feel over there what's going
on after coming back from obviously
there's no avoiding at Daniel's death
and losing a friend like that it's been
really tough on all of us but with you
guys as support we've been able to like
push forward in new ways that we thought
possible because I wanted to bring it
Ryan and Matt are standing awkwardly
over there well I'm talking about him so
come on guys over here on the squad over
here oh hey chica were over here yeah
what's going on
boo boo boo we filmed about 40 to 50
videos in preparation for this break and
that's the kind of work ethic that I
want when we come back especially
considering how ambitious the projects
we have are but I just want to say from
the heart thank you guys for supporting
us through this time because it hasn't
been easy for us because I can speak for
all of us that you know we remember
Daniel you know and the influence that
he had on us but like lately it's very
I'm very proud to say that you know
whenever we remember them it's never in
like a sad way
never like feel we feel the loss of
Daniel but we never like mourn his loss
every day it's always in a joking way
and were able to remember him in how he
inspired us to move forward in videos
and how we're carrying on in making
videos you know just because we don't
want that tragedy to bog us down
we don't want losing him to forever
hinder what we do and I can't speak for
you guys so maybe you guys could say
some words about it it's definitely
making all of us learn more um because
he he was a big like creative force in
on the team he was gonna originally like
teaching some music like now you're
doing that on your own a year and you're
like really pushing forward with that so
that's cool and just me I'm having to
learn more about the cameras matters I
just think we're all like being pushed
to learn different things and expand our
knowledge on it in yeah that helps with
us creating the content that we can
provide for you and so it's it's an
inspiration to definitely have to learn
more because you know gotta got to fill
the gap of editing and stuff so you have
to learn a little more and I guess like
the biggest thing is you don't want that
decision he made to you know ruin or
hinder our ambitions so yeah because you
know it is tragedy and we can always say
it's a tragedy but in a lot of ways it's
driven us more than we ever thought
possible because every single day you
guys don't see our daily life but every
single day like we get up I get up early
for they do their there a little later
but we try to get to work 10 a.m. every
day and they slog down and they get
their coffee and I'm like morning boys
you morning person I'm a wonderful
morning person and they are absolutely
not a morning person socially
yeah specially him but it's getting
better and then every day we start the
day and we always try to do something
new every day and when we get back we
have
so many big things planned and I can't
wait and you're obviously going to see a
lot of cool stuff that we do over
Christmas break and there's just so many
like really cool things that we get to
do and it's all thanks to you guys for
supporting us through this time and yeah
that's all I really wanted to say is
thank you guys so much for supporting us
and like I hope you guys have a great
holiday I hope you did too spend some
time with your family and friends
because I haven't seen my friends and
family in a couple months and I really
enjoy going back and spending time with
them and they're gonna go back to see
their families and then we're all going
to come back here and be stronger for it
and do even more cool things and have
even more fun making videos because at
the end of the day we have so much fun
doing this like it's not we say work and
what we're doing is like taking up all
the time every day we try something new
but it's fun
it's the most fun I've had making videos
in a long time because I get to do with
friends I get to push myself creatively
and I get to you know expand and try new
things and that's really cool and also
we got cheated yes who is a great
inspiration to all of us
she's you're seriously one of the best
dogs watch goopy up we're gonna scoop
you there we go there we go hey bub woof
here see it's almost like oh you
couldn't face dirty huh yeah see I get a
mess part yeah this is good port anyway
so just thank you guys everyone so much
for watching so much for supporting I
mean we've done like two new series
three new sketches random bloopers just
fun things the mini montages and that's
all in just a short amount of time and
then when we're gonna come back full
time for several month it's like so much
I've been doing this for almost four
years and I feel more creatively
fulfilled in the last few months that I
have in a long time so just thank you
everybody so much for watching and just
get ready for more cool stuff that we're
going to do in the future so as always
we'll see you in the next video bye j-mo
movie boy boy boy she's this way let me
down
that is unbearable